اعتقال الرعايه الاجانب في ايران يثير
مخاوف الولايات المتحده وبلدان اوروبيه من
مصير مجهول يخيم على مواطنها القابعين في
سجون طهران ففي الايام الاخيره فقط برزت
اربع قضايا ليراها اين يعانون من ظروف
احتجاز قاسيه وحتى اسباب اعتقالهم مشكوك
فيها
الامريكي الايراني سيا ماكنامازي المعتقل
منذ اكثر من سبع سنوات
رهينه الفرنسي الايرلندي
اعتقاله في اكتوبر الماضي بدريعه التجسس
وتقول الخارجيه الفرنسيه انه بحاجه
لمتابعه طبيه لا تتوافر في مكان احتجاجه
البلجيكي اوليفي فاليكاستل تم اعتقاله
ايران قبل عام وتصف الحكومه البلجيكيه هذا
الاعتقال بانه كان تعسفيا ومن دون ادله
حقيقيه على ما تروج له طهران بان الرجل
يعمل لصالح استخبارات اجنبيه بينما يعيش
حاليا في ظروف غير انسانيه اما اخر ضحايا
الاعتقالات الايرانيه ضد الرعايه الاجانب
فهو الماني بدريعه تصويره منشات نفطيه في
مدينه ايميدي دون الاعلان عن تفاصيل اخرى
او معرفه اسمه النظام الايراني وحسب سلطات
القضائيه
اجانب حيث تم تسجيل واحتقال مالا يقل عن
اربعين اجنبيه خلال الاحتجاجات المندلعه
منذ سبتمبر الماضي فيما يبرر النظام
الاعتقالات بانها تاتي بسبب المساسب الامن
القومي للبلاد وان الاعتقالات تمت بموجب
القانون وظهران مستعده لتبا سجن مع الغرب
ومع استمرار ايران في عمليه الاعتقالات
وحملات القمع وانتهاك حقوق الانسان توعدت
الولايات المتحده ودول اوروبيه بالرده
ووضع حد لنهج قائم على حجرها الى اجانب
كوارقه لمساومه الغرب